GILL or to get a free copy call 702-233-8883.
The proceeding has been paid for by Preach & Sing Records.
Hello and welcome to Hope for Health.
I'm Dr. Dan Royal.
Hope for Health is brought to you by New Hope Medical Center.
We invite you now to enjoy this informative program on health alternatives.
Thank you for being with us today.
This is a call-in radio talk show.
So those of you who are out there listening, if you would like some free health advice,
feel free to call us in.
650-KKVV is the call-in number, which is 650-5588.
If you're listening live on the internet or a long distance, you can reach us at 800-366-8883.
That's 800-366-8883.
Today's guest is a researcher and expert in the area of female hormones, and he received
his doctorate in philosophy and endocrine physiology and biochemistry from the University
of Oregon in 1972.
He has taught courses in endocrinology, physiology, the brain, and aging at such schools as the
National College of Naturopathic Medicine and the University of Oregon.
He is the author of several books, all of which I have read myself, which include progesterone
and orthomolecular medicine and nutrition for women, mind, and tissue.
He also has a monthly newsletter, which he's been writing since 1980, and to which I also
subscribe.
His name is Dr. Ray Peet, and we'd like to welcome him to the program.
Dr. Peet, welcome.
Thank you.
It's nice to have you with us.
You're there in Eugene, Oregon, isn't that correct?
We're here in Las Vegas, where the weather is sunny.
It's still a little warm for this time of year.
You're there where it's overcast.
I used to live there for 15 years, so I know exactly what it's like.
It's raining, actually.
Raining or drizzling, because everybody walks around there without an umbrella.
They're so used to it, the light drizzle.
When it's overcast so much of the time, are you familiar with much seasonal affective
disorder where people become depressed because they're not getting enough sunlight?
Yes.
Thirty-five years ago, when I moved to Eugene from southern Oregon, where there's a lot
more sun, I wondered why I was feeling lethargic and depressed.
Then I realized we hadn't had a day of sunlight for about two months straight.
That was when I really started getting interested in the hormonal effects of sunlight.
When I moved back, after being in Mexico for several years, I moved back to Eugene and
started seeing graduate student young women who had moved to Eugene and immediately started
having hormonal problems, PMS and worse symptoms.
What did you do for yourself to correct that problem?
Trying to get as much sunlight as possible.
When there's no sunlight, then I keep a couple of, they call them infrared bulbs, but they're
warmers, use them for brooder lamps to keep baby chicks warm and so on.
They have a clear front and a reflector built in, but they have a warmer temperature, lower
temperature than the usual incandescent bulb.
That means that the light penetrates more deeply.
It's rich in red and orange frequencies and I keep about 500 watts shining down on me
all the time when I'm indoors.
That sounds like a very interesting approach, similar to the infrared sauna, which can penetrate
deeper without having to overheat the patient.
What about using ultraviolet light?
Isn't that also a treatment?
I have about an 80-year-old mercury vapor lamp that I use for getting extra vitamin
D once in a while, but I also take some vitamin D. I like to take it through my skin because
I never have much confidence in how pure the excipients are in supplements, but taking
it through my skin works fine for keeping my vitamin D up.
We have the same concern in our clinic about using the best quality supplements because
a lot of products out there, especially the ones made by the pharmaceutical company, which
are very cheap but very ineffective, and so patients read about the great results that
you can get from taking certain B vitamins or vitamin E or amino acid and then they go
buy it on the cheap and wonder why they're not getting results.
Thirty years ago, I was doing a lot of counseling with allergic people.
In the summer, Eugene is near a big grass growing area, and at the end of the summer,
they burn the fields and release a lot of chemicals into the air, so the asthma sickness
rate is very high, but all summer there are lots of allergic people in Eugene.
I found at first that giving them supplements and a good diet, especially rich in vitamin
A and pandethenic acid, took care of a big part of the population with allergies, but
there were many that didn't improve, and I found that if I got them to use natural
foods and avoid all of their supplements, all of them improved.
It turned out that many, many people taking a lot of vitamin and mineral supplements every
day were actually allergic to the excipients in the products.
Yeah, that's a good point.
What happens in the patient, in our experience, is that patients have a threshold, and when
they are exposing themselves to allergens, whether in their food or in the air or even
from their supplements in this case, they all add up.
They have a cumulative effect, and then you reach that threshold at which they're reactive,
and sometimes lowering their reactivity to one of those agents may help lower their response,
their allergens, but the allergy is still there until they're neutralized and you're
able to identify what they are and eliminate them completely.
All they've done is...
The total burden and the amount of energy you have to deal with the burden is what produces
symptoms.
If your blood sugar is low, almost anything becomes a serious allergen.
With animal experiments, they found that the weakest allergen, if they lowered the blood
sugar with insulin, the animals would die in shock from a very weak allergen, but if
they gave them extra sugar, even the allergic animals, they would get nothing but mild sniffles
from a deadly, super strong allergen.
Now what about hypoglycemia or reactive hypoglycemia?
Patients are eating something that's raising their blood sugar and then it drops over a
short period of time.
Are those patients then...
Are these the patients that are more susceptible to allergies or that are reacting in an allergic
way?
It can become a vicious circle because normally when you are exposed to a stress or an allergen,
you put out a little extra cortisol to improve your immunity and lower your inflammation,
but that can start suppressing your thyroid function and lowering your liver's detoxifying
ability and your intestine always has allergens in it.
If you're exposed to some special allergen, the chronic exposure to cortisol suppressing
your liver function and thyroid function allows those toxins and allergens from your intestine
to get into the bloodstream.
Cortisol is a basic substance produced by bacteria in the intestine and that poisons
our energy producing systems.
It almost turns off mitochondrial function and that wastes the blood sugar so that you
can create hypoglycemia by exposing yourself to too many of these stresses.
The quickest way to break out of the cycle is to eat a well-balanced natural diet, but
emphasizing a lot of fruits.
Orange juice for example because of the high potassium content which lets you handle and
absorb blood sugar without disturbing your insulin.
The potassium itself handles the sugar without triggering the insulin and when your liver
is receiving enough sugar from the combination of potassium and sugar in the fruit, it is
able to activate the thyroid hormone restoring the poisoned function of your mitochondria
and letting you use oxygen efficiently.
So it can bring you out of a chronic allergic hypoglycemic state and get you back to a steady
blood sugar sometimes just in a day or two.
I think you mentioned a couple of things that most people are not aware of.
Number one is that orange juice has potassium in it.
Everybody thinks about eating bananas, but if you're low in potassium you can drink orange
juice and get it increased much quicker.
You also mentioned something about the liver which is an area where the thyroid is converted
from inactive to active form.
Most people don't understand.
Yeah, Bruno Barnes many years ago wrote a very good book called "Hypoglycemia, It's
Your Liver Not Your Mind" and he was one of the first people to emphasize that most of
the active thyroid, about 70% of it, is produced in your liver rather than in the thyroid gland.
The gland itself in your neck produces about 30% of the active hormone, but anytime your
blood sugar falls, if you go without eating for eight hours for example, your blood sugar
is likely to fall and your liver doesn't want to convert your tissues to food and so your
liver stops making thyroid so your metabolism decreases.
Your temperature goes down at some point when you have stopped eating so that you don't
burn up your body too fast as you would if your metabolic rate stayed high without eating.
Yeah, now we mentioned that the thyroid is produced by the thyroid, it's also produced
by the liver and we're converted there.
Doesn't that conversion also take place at the cellular level as well?
Several tissues produce quite a bit of it.
The pituitary gland can detect T4 because of the inactive form of the thyroid, thyroxine
and since it can convert it, it doesn't distinguish very strongly between whether you're taking
T4 or T3.
It turns off its activity whenever it sees T4 or T3 and so since it produces just a tiny
amount for its own detecting purposes, if you accumulate too much thyroxine in your
tissues, your pituitary thinks you have enough thyroid but your liver might not be producing
any active thyroid hormone from it at all.
In one of the early experiments studying where the hormone is active and what it's doing,
they took slices of the different organs and added thyroxine and they found that the liver
became fully activated with a modest amount of thyroxine added.
The kidneys converted a little of it and were slightly activated by thyroxine.
The muscles were not activated at all but the brain when thyroxine was added was actually
suppressed because the brain normally has an extremely high concentration of the active
T3 part of the hormone in relation to T4 and so locally, too much T4 affects your brain
in an anti-thyroid direction but very few doctors are aware of the risks of prescribing
plain thyroxine.
There's a lot of evidence that there's a high concentration of T3 in the bloodstream.
There's a high concentration of T3 in the bloodstream, there's a high concentration of T3 in the
liver and there's a high concentration of T3 in the bloodstream.
There's a high concentration of T3 in the bloodstream.
There are three times when women are more likely to become hypothyroid.
You can see the thyroid gland enlarging around puberty, pregnancy, and menopause.
What happens is they've studied it with slices of the tissue in a culture dish.
As estrogen rises, the brain senses that you need more thyroid hormone and puts out more TSH.
The thyroid gland stops secreting the active hormone.
Progesterone activates those enzymes and allows the gland to secrete.
Puberty is the most common one.
Typically, girls in their teens will have an enlarged thyroid compared to boys.
We would typically put the patient on a grain of the natural thyroid and have them take it twice a day.
The natural thyroid has a half-life of about 8-12 hours.
We're going to go ahead and take a short break.
We'll be right back.
[Music]
>> First, I think we should clarify that Wilson's syndrome is primarily referring to that reverse T3.
That's another element of thyroid testing that can be assessed.
I think the question you had, Dr. Peet, was how accurate, number one, is the basal body temperature, and number two, can the problem of Wilson's syndrome be corrected with T3?
>> Well, I think that the stress hormones causing a falsely elevated normal appearing temperature, that's something that you should watch out for.
If someone has had an unusual diet without enough protein or if they're in the menopause years,
it's very common for women to experience excess cortisol around menopause.
The deposit of fat around the trunk at menopause and the weakening of the bones,
cortisol accelerates dissolving of the bones and deposition of fat.
So people with those symptoms, even if they're younger, they should be checked for excess adrenaline and cortisol.
Protein deficiency is a common cause of that whole pattern.
The reverse T3 rises when you're under stress and exposed to too much cortisol.
A very bad diet can be enough to put you into that chronic stress state.
The easiest way out of it is with a supplement, a reliably formulated supplement of T3.
The armor thyroid and a traditional product made by the same company called ThyroLar,
which was a synthetic made to be equivalent to the natural thyroid,
is a good way to get rid of the cortisol.
The T3 is a good supplement.
It's not a good supplement for most people.
People almost always prefer to have a little more T3 than that if they want to quickly get over their symptoms.
We've talked about this program such as the low T4, low T3, the high TSH, the thyroid antibodies,
not to mention the clinical conditions that need to be looked at.
For example, you could have a patient that has normal thyroid function,
but yet they have clinical symptomatology, signs and symptoms, hypothyroidism.
What are you going to do?
Most doctors would not treat because the lab says they're fine.
You don't need a doctor to diagnose a patient who's fine in the lab.
You can assess whether the patient has thyroid even though the lab is abnormal and be able to explain why.
The traditional doctors did fine just going by signs.
As many of the measures as they knew were reliable, such as oxygen consumption and the cholesterol level.
They would look at the palms of a person's hands.
A low thyroid person can't convert carotene to vitamin A,
so they will typically accumulate orange in the calluses of their hands and feet.
Their hands and feet are almost always cold because their metabolic rate is low.
Even though their core temperature might be kept up by adrenaline and cortisol,
their fingers and toes are likely to be cooler than other people's at the same environmental temperature.
Cold feet, interestingly, can cause serious inflammatory problems elsewhere in the body.
A first aid for some of the symptoms of hypothyroidism is just to get some woolly underwear and thick stockings.
You can also correct that by keeping your adrenals warm because you can actually cure anemia
even without correcting your whole metabolic situation just by keeping your long bones warmer
and reducing the inflammatory substances produced in cold feet.
That's very interesting.
You can also correct that by supplementing the adrenals so they don't have to put out so much adrenaline
and natural DHA and pregnenolone hormones.
But some of the clinical signs of hypothyroidism, which are very obvious and, of course, taken together,
should raise your index of suspicion and they include fatigue, overweight or obesity, and edema, among other things.
Anyway, we have a caller on the line and I think she has a question for our guest.
Earlene, did you have a question you'd like to ask?
I don't know if it will be related or not, but what I was wondering is the change of...
I had a hysterectomy when I was 36 and I'm now 73.
I'm diabetic, but I don't take any insulin and I don't take any diabetic medicine.
I've been trying to control it with diet.
But what I'm worried about is my arthritis seemed to get worse after I had the hysterectomy.
And I have osteoarthritis, not the other kind.
I was wondering if this had anything to do with hormones.
Absolutely, hormones are related.
And one of the things that should be checked, in my opinion, is the female hormones along with the thyroid.
And other more comprehensive testing to give us a bigger picture of what's going on.
But as Dr. P. mentioned earlier, as a woman goes through menopause, this is one of those transitions in life
where the hypothyroidism issue can manifest.
And some people also have the theory that when you're in pain or inflammation all the time,
that your cortisol level may actually not be quite high enough.
And so that's keeping you in pain all the time.
So these are some issues that should be considered.
What do you think, Dr. Pete?
I had a friend who was in his 70s and had an accident and immediately started developing arthritis.
And was crippled pretty suddenly by arthritis in his hands and feet and knees.
And he luckily had a doctor who had been educated in the 1930s
who immediately tested his thyroid because stress and injury can lower your thyroid.
And my friend was grumpy and said, "I didn't go to have you fix my thyroid.
I wanted you to fix the arthritis."
But within two weeks his arthritis cleared up and he lived 15 years more with never any more arthritis.
In the 30s it was standard knowledge that arthritis was usually a sign of hypothyroidism.
Yeah, that's a good point.
I mean, any trauma in your life like having a baby or having a surgery,
these things can trigger hypothyroidism because it's such a stress from which you may not recover.
And as Dr. Pete said, you need a doctor with a little more intuition who uses his right brain
and can diagnose these problems without being wholly reliant upon the lab.
Anyway, we thank you for calling, Earline.
We're going to take a short break and when we come back we'll continue our discussion with Dr. Ray Pete.
I'm Dr. Dan Royal and you're listening to Hope for Health.
We'll be right back.
Hi, I'm Dr. Dan Royal, Medical Director for New Hope Medical Center.
Every day I see patients who suffer from the effects of modern living such as stress, pollution, allergies and even prescription drugs.
I believe we all deserve to feel as good as we can to be optimally well.
That's why at New Hope we emphasize health optimization, not disease management.
For more information call New Hope Medical at 476-0000.
Learn the secrets to living a great life by consulting with a doctor who really cares about you and your health.
Call 476-0000 now.
Does your back ache? Is your neck in pain? Would you like to be pain-free? Then get Vax-D.
Vax-D is a non-surgical treatment clinically proven to be successful in over 86% of patients with back pain,
sciatica, embulging, herniated or degenerative discs.
Vax-D gently decompresses the area of injury and pain, draws nutrients into the area and promotes relaxation and repair.
For more information call New Hope Medical at 476-0000.
Take your life back. Get pain-free with Vax-D.
Call 476-0000 now and make your appointment for Vax-D treatment today.
Hi, I'm back. I'm Dr. Dan Royal. You're listening to Hope for Health.
My guest today has been Dr. Ray Peet.
We're winding down our show here but we're going to go ahead and take one more caller.
Bill, you're on the line. Do you have any questions for our guest?
Well, kind of, sort of, it's not more, mostly a question. I was born with Wilson's disease and have lived with it.
Through diet and nutrition, I have kept it under control and I was on KKVV for about three and a half years
with stepping to the other side of health.
So, I have a vague idea to Wilson's disease from the inside, so to speak, having had it.
Sure.
And had it all my life.
One of the things that people will tell you is that you can't live without fat.
And I'm living proof. I'm past 75 and I'm living proof that you can live without eating fat.
So, if sometime in the future you ever want to get around to discussing Wilson's again, I'll be more than happy to call in again.
All right. Appreciate your call. Thanks, Bill. You have a great day.
Thank you. You too.
Although I do advocate eating saturated fats, they can have some therapeutic effects.
I'm also an advocate of fruit-centered diet.
There are animals that live on fruit, for example, the squirrel monkey, which lives about three times as long as other animals of its size
and has an extremely high metabolic rate.
And in the wild, it lives exclusively on fruit.
And that's sort of a way to think about the effect of fruit on your physiology, because the fruit contains the things needed to stimulate your thyroid function and protect against stress.
So, it is possible to live entirely without fat in your diet because your body can make the saturated fats that it needs.
That's a good point, but saturated fat is what the thyroid needs, and you can get that from coconut oil, which I use in my own cooking.
And on the other hand, you have a lot of patients who are taking these unsaturated fatty acids, which are actually inhibiting thyroid.
Yeah, the more unsaturated the fat is, the more thoroughly it inhibits the thyroid.
It inhibits secretion, transport, and reaction to the thyroid.
And in the early part of the last century, several researchers showed that animals on a fat-free diet were completely free of spontaneous cancer and lived longer than normal.
Yeah, that's very interesting. But at the very least, a patient, if they're taking unsaturated fat, shouldn't be combining it with saturated fat, so they have to come to balance.
Anyway, we're coming to the conclusion of our show. Thank you. My man in the sound room over there is roaring like a lion.
So, Dr. Pete, any concluding remarks for our listeners today?
Well, there's a book that you might be able to find in a big library or a used bookstore that is really a great introduction to the amazing things that thyroid can do.
It's "The Thyroid" by Thomas McGavick.
Okay, "Thyroid" by Thomas McGavick. I appreciate being with us, Dr. Pete. This has been very interesting, and I hope it's been interesting for you, our audience.
I'm Dr. Dan Royal. You've been listening to Hope for Health, which is brought to you by New Hope Medical Center, located here in town, where you can find us at 215 N. Pecos.
We invite you to tune in again this same time again next week for another important program on health alternatives with Hope for Health.
Until then, you have a great life.
Who are all these people, Lisa? And how do they know who you are?
I used all the money I saved on my motorcycle insurance to buy my own fame. Isn't it great?
to buy my own fame. Isn't it great?